From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emily Crosby on December 10th, 2015, and we're with Freddie Greene at the Library of Congress.
This is part of the Civil Rights History Project, and it's co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History.
And John Bishop is also here.
Thanks so much again for joining us.
Can you start by telling us when and where you were born and about your family?
Sure. Well, I was born in Greenwood, Mississippi, which is in the heart of the Mississippi Delta in 1945, February 15, 1945.
And I grew up in a large black family that both my parents were originally from Mississippi and always lived there.
My father in the early 60s had been involved often on with the NAACP, so my father was a small business person, had a house painting business where the majority of his work was.
And I was close to the White community.
And my mother had taught school up until the time she married my father and she married my father when she was 29.
So at that stage in time, being 29 and getting married was kind of late in life.
Well, she talked about growing up in Greenwood. She actually grew up in Greenwood. She grew up in the exact same house that I grew up in.
Actually, my great-grandmother had owned and built that house.
And my mother came after she married my father. My father was a farmer.
And he carried her to live on the farm. And to my mother who had grown up in Greenwood, even though Greenwood was a very small thing, farming just was not for her.
She said it was just too quiet. It was too dark and it was nobody to talk to.
Now, she had grown up in Greenwood in the 1600s of a Howard Street, which was just across the railroad from downtown Greenwood.
So all of her life, she's pretty much been a setting girl.
And she went to the church to Wesley, which is used to say that she and her mother went to Wesley every time the church doors open.
And the church was like two blocks from where they lived.
My mother had had kind of interesting life. She basically grew up in that house. Her mother owned a little florist shop and her father owned a barber shop.
So that was like a few blocks away. So they were little business people.
But when my mother was a child, she had had a brother and the brother had kicked in the head by a horse directly in front of the house.
So as a result, it was just the two of them. And my mother says that her mother became overly protective of her.
So this was a traumatic experience of losing a child at five years old directly in front of your house.
And it means something that you wouldn't think that would happen.
You know, your two little kids are out front playing, but somebody ties a horse and wagon to the tree that's outside.
And then, inadvertently, these two little kids go to close. And the horse kicks my uncle's in the head.
And so that's the end.
Yeah, so it was very, very traumatic. And my mother, so from then on, my mother was the only child.
And then she just went back with some horse all the time to church, however.
That's how she was allowed to do. She went to church.
And doing those years in Greenwood, there was no...
The only school that she went to was a private school that she went to.
Then she went away to go to high school. And she went to Tougaloo to high school doing the...
This one is because at that time Tougaloo had a high school.
She went there to high school. And she also went there to stay there on the college and stuff.
And then she came back to live with her mother and live there while she taught school up until she married my father.
That's an indication, I guess, of how a lot of parents must have lived.
Well, I think that...
Also, you have to consider the fact that it was only one child.
And I guess they were better off than most people, because you're talking about probably less than two percent of the black people in the flow county own properties.
So just to the fact that her mother had inherited this house from her mother, you know, that did give her a little bit of a privilege.
Now my father in return had grown up on the farm. He and his brother. And he only had one brother.
And my father could relate to you because my father went to...
When he got ready to go to high school and to college, he went to Alcorn.
Out in the woods. And my daddy used to say that when they went to college, they went in the fall.
And they didn't come home to the spring. So you stayed through the entire year.
All of that, you spent it all that school. You could not come home. I mean, transportation.
So daddy says that the school would bring the wagon down to the train station to pick up the trunks.
And then the boys and the girls would all follow the wagon back to school.
So that was his whole... But it was like, it was nothing but country.
It's still nothing. But that's... So that was his idea of Lohmann.
And he didn't like it. He thought it was too rural. He wanted to see something else.
And he convinced his folks. They sent him a one-year. He went to Tuskegee Institute to...
To take up shoemaking because he wanted to do something.
And he didn't... He said he really didn't want to farm, but he wanted to do something.
But he wanted to work for himself. I mean, he had a thing that he did not want to work for anybody.
Did his parents own their own farm?
They own their farm, yeah. And out in the area where he lived, his family owned there.
There was another two other black families around that also owned their land.
And we were talking about... Because my father was born in 1900. His brother was born in 1898.
So we were talking about an older generation of people.
And it's... Basically, there were these little pockets where families had own land.
And they had held very, very tight. I mean, people lived off the land.
They farm, they raise animals. They had gardens and all.
I mean, dad used to talk about the time that he and his brother saw somebody stealing the truck.
But they didn't realize that the guys were... They was his truck, that the guys were stealing.
They saw these men struggling, pushing this truck. They got off the back porch to go out to help.
And as they started down the road, the guys took off running.
And then they said, we wouldn't until they got close. They realized that that's why they were running.
It was their truck, that they would take it.
So that's what...
So that's... I mean, that's the way it was. People helped people.
Did your grandparents still have that farm when you were a child?
Well, my grandparents did. My uncle sold it. My grandparents, three of my grandparents died.
The year was first grade, which was in 1951, died in 1951. The fall of 1951 and the other two died.
They were doing the spring in 1952. And yeah, it was first grade.
My uncle actually sold the farm probably in the late 50s.
Because his uncle was one of the two black postmen in Greenwood.
That's a good job.
It was an extremely good job. I mean, they were like that.
They used to say that uncle and this other man, Mr. Dickson, was the postman.
And they had very, very good jobs. And so did there was another man, Mr. Thompson, who cleaned up the post office.
And all of these were definitely considered to be very, very good jobs.
Because they basically had benefits.
And my father always contributed towards his social security.
And my daddy had a strong thing about that he felt that that was going to support him as he grew older.
Because my parents had grown up. My father, 1900, my mother was born in 1907.
Of course, they knew about history before social security and how people did not have any food and stuff
and have the ability to support themselves. And obviously, if they weren't social security,
there were definitely people working that made in somebody's house and in field hands had no pension plans.
And were not eligible for social security?
And were not eligible for social security.
So there wouldn't have been that many people in the community doing it.
So that's what kind of unusual...
Well, yeah, I mean, my daddy did it. And so did he had another good friend.
And Mr. Hilton, who also had another little business.
I think that, and they both used to talk back-and-forth with other people who had small businesses trying to encourage a person to do it.
And the real question and what daddy always said was that the question of whether this was going to work.
Because it was talking about something that you were told about that you had never experienced and never knew anyone else who had it experience.
And you had to have faith that when you're writing, doing out this form and depositing money over in an account that's supposed to be there for you,
when you receive, when you reach the certain age to be able to retire.
And that daddy had faith. And his friend did, but as he said, most people didn't.
From time to time, when he had other painters to work for him, most of them, no one wanted to do that.
Because as far as they were concerned, you're given your money away.
Did you have any experience with how it worked or when it really did work?
No, no one had any experience. I mean, you're talking about, in 35, when this is really first being introduced.
And that you also are talking about generation of most black people who didn't have much formal education and you're doing everything you can to survive.
And no one is really providing you with huge amount of information on how this is working.
This is all before the Internet.
It's an act of faith.
It's an act of faith. However, he just had faith that this was really going to work.
And as it turns out, the Social Security process was probably one of the things that was able to help my father.
Because as we began to, as a family, get involved in the movement, less and less jobs, people called that a fall.
So as a result, in 1964, he literally had to retire on his Social Security because he was not getting work.
People would not call him for a job.
Now, the good thing is that it correlated with the same time that he was really eligible for Social Security.
I mean, if he had been a younger person, it would have been much harder and stuff.
And I think that that was the other advantage that I had with growing up with older parents that they had a little bit more advantage than people who were no fresh out much younger.
When the movement was being in the movement, strength, pressure against your family, they were in a position where they could withstand it.
They could withstand it. They owned the house and dad it was able to draw his Social Security.
I mean, I think that that was that made life easier.
Before we start talking about the movement, can you talk about what your schools were like and what happened?
Can you give us a picture of what dream was with life?
Well, now, consider that. I grew up on Howard Street.
If you looked at a map then, the 600 block was, there was a railroad track that really separated the block that I lived in from downtown.
So if the 500 block of Howard Street, there would have been a go-birds, there was a shoe store, so it's all downtown Greenwood that's going that way.
We are also on the edge of the streets going. So that's going north.
So if you then were talking about the East West, streets go over about four other blocks and then you're in the white neighborhood.
So we are technically living on the, even though that's the oldest part of the city where I grew up, it's really on the edge of the black community when I was growing up.
So we could technically at my house hear the white kids over at the playground, at the park.
You could hear them in the park playing. So, I mean, so we're that close to that community.
So the school, we all walked, all the black kids walked the school.
And I do believe all the white kids walked the school except for the kids who lived outside the city limits.
And that was always one of the big problems that my father had is that they used to say all the time they had school buses that they went around and picked up kids in the counties.
White kids in the counties and brought them into school so that they went to better schools.
That his tax dollars was really paying for that his children could go to.
My schools were all segregated. The school books in my school came from the white school.
So as white kids got new textbooks, they then shipped over textbooks to the black schools.
And considering the fact that I started school in 1951, so you're talking about, and I graduated in 1963 and schools were still totally segregated in Greenwood.
So much of Brown.
Yeah, so much of urban Brown. I think they did not desegregate, even start desegregating the schools in Greenwood until 1970.
Yeah, they didn't have freedom of choice.
Yeah, yeah. So we basically went, but what did happen is after the Supreme Court decision, what Mississippi did do is they began to build high schools in small communities.
Now Greenwood was one of the communities that had a high school. So as a result, a lot of black families that could send their children in, no found people to get for their kids to be able to stay with, to be able to go to high school.
So people out in the county and people all like that, but that was something that you had to organize yourself. I mean, it was no system in that.
If you were lucky enough to know somebody to be able to, for your kids to be able to stay with.
Yeah.
So after Brown, they did like you're talking about, they built a new school. At the same time, they actually started providing buses to bring black children from the county in the poor districts.
Oh, yeah.
It's one of those things they did after Brown.
Yeah, well, they definitely built high schools. And the high school proud to Brown became the junior high school, and they built a new high school.
And they just began to build high schools all around.
Did they bring any of the county kids that they should be able to come to the county kids in the poor district?
No, what they did do in the early 60s is they built a county school for the kids. And then they had to go to the county school.
So they did pick them up for the kids and have Amanda Elsie that they built in the 60s, yes.
And that was solely for the county kids.
Okay.
What are some of your first few memories of race in the rare race?
Well, first is we didn't, we were, schools were all segregated.
We only went downtown when, with our parents, when we went specifically to buy something, school clothes, when it's time to go.
The whole process was that we went, what we call window shopping to look at things so that you went and looked in the one then we did that with mom and daddy.
And one of the biggest things I remember is my folks always talked about keeping you safe.
And they did not want to downtown. They didn't want you around different areas.
And there was a block from where I lived. There was a guy who had a little corner store.
And my father, it was a white guy. And my father didn't allow us to go in there because he said that the judges didn't treat people right.
So he did not want to, you to deal with that.
Growing up in a completely segregated community like that, you really don't, since there's no real reason to go downtown, my contact was with all black people most of the time.
We had a telephone and we probably won a few people who had a straight, what's considered to be a straight line because a lot of people had what's called a party line.
And there's like several different people who share the same line. And so as a result they do it.
But my father said that for his business, he needed this private line. So he had this line.
But the phone was strictly for business. It was where people called him about jobs and stuff.
And we answered the phone, took messages and all of that for him. But the phone was clearly business.
And occasionally somebody would come by to ask him about, come by to see him about work.
As I said, and these were all white people. I did notice across the street from us, there were people who came by to pick up their mates.
There were some people who picked up their mates and carried them back with them forwards to work.
There were also people who dropped off the laundry that people did on and for folks. So it was all of that.
But just coming directly in contact with white people, we just didn't do it.
The superintendent of schools was always white. And the superintendent of schools used to come to the schools once a year for commencement.
And he would make out, he was always first on the program. And he would make his five or ten minute little speech and then he would accept.
During the time when I was in high school, our football team was really good. And they were big eight champions.
So that was the division that we actually played in. So what happened is that they would occasionally bring in the white football team to watch.
And they set up their special bleaches down for the boys from that team to watch the team and play football.
And then they, I mean, football is big in the South. So they used to do that. So they'd succumbed by for that.
But there was no interaction. Like I could not tell you a single person's name.
There was no white person that was growing up at the same time. Because I just had no interaction with them whatsoever.
And my father was determined that we were not going to work. I mean, a lot of people did like, baby said and little stuff like that.
But my father was no. He did take my brothers out in painting houses with him.
But they were working for him, not for that. And then that was like doing that summertime. But for the girls and that was four of us.
And none of us were involved in doing that. It was one of the things that to make sure that he kept his family safe.
And my father had a real proudness about the fact that he felt that he was able to support his family.
You know, he felt very, very good about that.
Did you have a sense of him being protective at the time? Did you understand that?
I think I understood that more. I do remember when in Muteil was killed.
His actually body was brought into a funeral home there in Greenwood.
And there was all the squirrsparing about what really happened to the boy and stuff.
And my father was always very protective and always saying that if you don't do what he said, you things could happen.
And he wanted to make sure that nothing happened to any of his children.
Did you see where you were? So the said, he said his body was in Greenwood?
Yeah, that was a whisper about that after the body was taken out.
I remember my parents had said that he is that the funeral homes were all nervous about which one of them, none of them really wanted it.
But because nobody wanted to get involved in what had happened.
That was worried about what had happened.
I mean, my mother had once talked about that she had heard when she was growing up about a person being burned alive.
So all of these are gruesome tales and all of this that one is always cautious about what could really happen to you.
So it was always being very, very careful that nothing was going to happen.
There were Mississippi was considered to be a complete dry state when I was growing up.
And that was dry in terms of no liquor, no beer, no nothing.
But people, there were people who sold liquor and stuff.
And my father used to always say that one of the problems with the people who were bootlegging and all of that is that they basically had made a pack with the folks downtown.
So that he said that you know you have to be very careful about them is that they have to provide information so they can stay in business.
So he said that sometimes if they don't have information they make up stuff on people.
So they would like that accommodation of those folks that it was just saying you got to watch out for.
And you were just very, very careful.
It was always the question of being careful about what you did and where you went.
And that it would tell you if he was here you would say I know all the good people in town.
I know all the bad people do so that's the reason why.
And that's the reason why you have to do that.
I've been in Greenwood and it seems to me that Greenwood is the starkest any place I've ever been in terms of the contrast between the white part of town and the white part of town.
Did you ever have any reason to go in the white part of town?
Never.
I know how the difference was mainly because I had you know, you know I did have my tonsils removed.
I mean the hospital was over in the white part of town.
But now Greenwood not only in terms of that but Greenwood has the large Jewish community did and they had that little community where they lived.
So the that you should say is the North Greenwood and North Greenwood was considered to be these were the old folks who probably traced their roots back to the plant.
And these were people who really had money.
Then there was the other the regular white folks who only thing they had going for themselves is that they were white and they went to the better schools and we did.
And then there was the Jewish community.
When I was growing up throughout the black community there were Chinese people and the Chinese people had these little small grocery stores.
But the Chinese people lived above their stores.
Now their children went to the white school but they lived in the black community.
So I know people that was over near the school where they lived.
They used to play with the Chinese kids in the neighborhoods.
Now there were no Chinese over here and I were in neighborhoods so I definitely never played with them.
A block from us was a little strip where about four different white families lived with children played but we never played with them.
For people who don't who can't visualize it can you paint us a quick picture of what the differences between the different parts of town were.
I think that most of the black community were what we call shotgun houses.
They were little and they were houses that were built also on, they sat like on pillows just about.
A brick stack, a brick and three room houses one right behind the other one throughout the black community.
Some places there were sidewalks, there were some places that were not sidewalks.
There was also throughout the black community. There were places where you were not sidewalks where you went across a plank which really means that you're really going across an open sewer.
And that's how people and that's probably how it was in the majority of the black community.
Now as I said in the older part of the black community over in the area where I lived is that we're still talking about frame houses.
We're talking about I mean these are just older houses.
I'm concerned that my mother was born in 1907 and her mother had been born in like 1874.
They had all lived in this house and over time the family had added more and more space onto it.
But my great grandmother had originally owned that land so it was like a little piece here and there.
Now because we lived inside the city you were not allowed to raise chickens or anything like that.
People did my grandmother had had a garden. My mother was not into garden and so she did not.
So when my grandmother was alive there were vegetables and stuff.
Otherwise we bought those from the farmers who came into town with that.
But in the white community you're talking about in North Green with this huge the anti-bellum houses.
So they would divide growing on them.
So some of those are really beautiful back in.
No that's in the olden days.
Then in the regular white community there's still frame houses.
I mean brick houses are an inception to the rule.
I mean that's really when you're talking about this white.
Then right before, right in the early 60s they build up what they called a housing development.
And there's people were coming back from the war.
They were finally able to get.
Because I think part of the problem is that it was no way to get financing for a house.
So then these GI's were coming back.
And they did build up this little development which was directly across the street from the high school.
But that was still you're talking about four room houses.
You know a very small place.
But at least this was for the first time that people began to see an opportunity to be able to buy a place.
Or to have a more space.
And I think that's the problem is it just happened decent housing.
And rather than all of these families having to live in these three shotgun houses.
And I've heard it out.
It's true that some of the shotgun houses will move from plantation.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
I mean I'm not sure.
But I mean you're talking about really, you're talking about frame houses and frame houses that over time,
if maintenance is not done and people don't own the houses.
So you got the wood just deteriorates over time.
I mean that's part of the reason why they painted.
No to protect the wood and stuff.
So you're talking about these frame houses as vending.
You're also talking about large families that have to live there.
Because this is the only place that they actually have to live.
So it's kind of a rough.
Yeah.
What do you remember about how did you first encounter the movement?
Well, my father had been involved in the end of the ACP.
I mean my father and mother really had registered to vote in the late 50s,
even though they actually never voted.
They had registered to vote.
So my father had been involved often with the end of the ACP.
Then in 1962, they just mentioned that they had done it.
But people talked about registered and the vote.
This was whisper in kind of thing.
This was not something that you wanted to advertise because it was always...
My father definitely always let you know that you never knew who you were talking to.
And that some people would just call struggle, you know.
But in 1962, my brother, Dwight, had just returned from doing a tour in the Navy.
And he applied and was going to, at that time,
he was Mississippi Vocational College.
And now it's Mississippi Valley State University.
In Itta Bena, Mississippi, he was going there.
But he wanted to go to Ole Miss.
So he applied...
Well, in Mississippi, if you went to college the only thing you could take was education.
And he didn't want education.
So he wanted to find something else to do.
So he applied to be the second black student at Ole Miss.
Now he did not get accepted.
But that began to cause a lot of attention, more attention on my family.
So that he...
But that is said that he got a call from the mayor that come downtown.
They wanted to talk to him.
You know, come downtown as quick as you can.
So that is just said that he said, well, he wouldn't...
He'd come, just come home from work.
He said he figured he'd go down and see the man in the morgue.
He went down.
And he told him, your boy applied to go to Ole Miss.
And we want you to tell him to take back his application.
So that is said that he said he told him, well, you know, I can't tell him to take back his application.
He said, I didn't tell him to apply, but I won't tell him to take it back.
So he said that the mayor told him, well, you better think about it.
And so that is how that whole conversation ended.
So he didn't get in.
So then he went to work for the Mississippi Free Press,
which was a small little newspaper that was given out in Jackson.
So do we begin to meet other political active people, Robert Parris Moses and his SNCC cohort that was...
Because at that time, SNCC had people down in Southwest Mississippi.
And he also met Medgar Evers.
So Robert Parris Moses was putting that...
He met Robert Parris Moses.
He met Sam Block.
He met Willie Peacock, Reggie Robinson.
All the people who were then down in the southern part of...
These are people down in the southern part.
He also met...
God, that...
I can't think of his name right now over in Cleveland,
who was Amzie Moore.
Amzie Moore.
And Amzie Moore said, well, I mean, he was...
Because Amzie Moore was interested in the Free Press.
And he said, because the Free Press probably was the only kind of paper
that basically was given out factual information,
or what was really going on.
So he and Amzie Moore had cultivated this relationship.
He said, well, Amzie Moore said, I'll help distribute your paper
and you can help me get things in the paper.
So it was like this was how things basically was done, you know.
Making things work.
So all of this began to hit.
And then Willie Peacock and Sam Block came into Greenwood that summer.
So this is like the summer.
So we're into the fall of 62 and they're coming in and stuff.
And I just began to go to Mass Meedens,
because as they began to have mass meetings,
now we talk about mass meetings all the time.
We do it.
We give a new definition to Mass.
You think about Mass as men as huge crowd.
Sometimes it may have been 20 people.
But we call them Mass Meedens.
A Mass meeting, there was the Hollis Watkins version that comes in with the singing
to arouse people, to try to encourage people to register the vote.
So it's like, to start now with singing to now give some type of spiritual
uplifting and to encourage people to get people involved.
And then that's different speakers that from time to time.
I mean, Medgar Evers with some Robert Parris Moses and all of this,
all to talk to people about trying to get folks to register the vote.
So we're going to all of these.
I'm going my brother George,
who's like 18 months older than me.
And George is like really going.
So we are all involved in trying to do this.
This is that whole...
My father did.
My mother was not very much involved.
She did not go, but my father did.
And we go to all of this now.
At this time, Mississippi in Leflore County, Mississippi,
surplus food is being distributed to people.
People are really having a hard time surviving.
Because Mississippi, in the Delta area,
so many of the people had lived out,
have been cotton pickers.
And in 62 was probably the first time they began to introduce the cotton pickers
into the, no, the electric machines to pick the cotton.
So the people then are not making much money,
because they're picking up after the pickers have come through the machines.
And it's a very hot winner for them.
It's cold.
They haven't made much money.
And people are trying to survive.
So they really do need the surplus food.
And we're not talking about luxury.
We're talking about powdered milk.
No.
Some teas, products, peanut butter.
And so it's little leads.
But this is what people needed to survive.
So that in Leflore County, Mississippi, they discontinued the food.
It's surplus food to all these people.
And this is as result of people getting involved in the movement.
So that made it extremely difficult.
So as results, throughout the North and Dick Gregory,
rented a plane and brought down surplus, brought down food down.
And the food was distributed from Wesley,
Methodist Church, which is two blocks from where I lived.
And I met my church.
And we helped with the distributed food.
Because I'm too young to register the vote.
I can do, and this is one of the things I can do.
And that's when it became very clear.
And my dad had what Stephanie is saying.
He said, they are trying their best to stop these people to death.
Because it's all they have.
It's this little dried milk and peanut butter.
And they are discontinuing the commodities for the people.
So on the one hand, there's less need for labor.
And on the other hand, people are trying to register the vote.
Right.
And as a result, Mississippi says,
we are going to do everything we can to stop you from doing this.
What was it like for you, you're a high school student.
And did you have a big Gregory Charter in a plane?
Well, I mean, that was like...
I was not that familiar with who Dick Gregory was.
I mean, he was now, wasn't in Tateena.
But I was not.
But it was a real big surprise.
And it was a welcome idea that somebody really did care about these people.
So it was a big effort when he brought into plane and brought in food and stuff.
And then even when Ivanhoe Donaldson, the son was driving down a truckload of food from the north.
That was also the idea that people really was trying their best to help.
Yeah.
So what was your job at the church?
To help distribute the food.
We would divide the stuff, bagging, boxing up things, helping distribute it to families.
So what do you remember about the SNCC workers coming into town?
What was your impression of it?
Well, I felt very good.
Because it was like, one, it was people who always talk to you about different things.
And it was like, Stokely Carmichael would tell me about growing up in New York and about his family being from Trinidad.
So it was like, it was a lot of information.
It was, it was an exposure to something else other than Mississippi as it was.
And people used to watch the soap operas, no, on television.
And it's just like, all of a sudden it was very clear to me that that was an outside world.
That you could see other than things that you read about in the books.
Because growing up, it was nothing to do.
And so the library used to be, the public library was not open to us.
What the used to do is that at the junior high school they would open up that library two days during the week.
So at least you could go and check out books.
But there was no summer programs.
There was nothing to do.
So as a high school person growing up, there was nothing.
So now all of a sudden I have all of these people who are coming down, who are college students,
and they are going to all of the schools who have just heard about.
I mean Harvard, Yale, I mean this is the Howard.
And I had never known anybody to go to all of this.
So I just feel that it is so much information out there.
And my father is encouraging me to do it.
Now I can remember I was a senior in high school and I met Eleanor Holmes,
who was in law school.
And it would be interesting to what was possible.
Well it definitely made it very clear there was a lot of things that was possible.
I mean she was going to Yale.
I mean it was, Tim Jenkins.
I met all of these when I was in high school.
And it just gave me, and people talked to you about other things that was going on.
Who are some of those people locally in your community who are leaders?
Well I guess when you talk about leaders, I guess most people think about the teachers as been.
And none of the teachers were involved in the Civil Rights Movement.
They were not.
And I think most of it was people were terrified of losing their jobs.
June Johnson's mother was, June Johnson's mother was involved in the movement.
The McGee family who owned a farm.
They didn't live directly in Greenwood but only outside of Greenwood.
They were very involved in the movement.
Reverend Johnson who had owned a, they had this little church.
And his church was called the First Christian Church.
Up until he had the, and he had the first mass meeting with Heldeth his church.
Then the wife folks said that he could not be the First Christian Church because they had the First Christian Church downtown.
And he had had this church as the First Christian Church for years.
But then the wife people said no, you can't.
So he had to change the name of the church.
And I can't think of now what the name of his church is.
But his church had to be, even though clearly there was, everyone would know that which was which.
But they, but he had to change the name.
And he was a, he's Aaron Johnson.
He was a big activist in the Hobick movement.
Tucker, Sterling Tucker was also, was another minister that was involved.
And you see, you had ministers who would get out and do things.
You had the McGee family, you had the Johnson's, and you had us, the Greens, and you printed my tummy.
People were afraid.
I mean, people, I mean, that, it became very, very clear to me that people were definitely very much afraid.
And they were afraid that you were going to make something happen to them.
You know.
So the people started avoiding?
People, they just, they want to be involved in the movement.
You know, I mean, so it was clear lines between people who were movement,
who were involved, and people were not.
And doing march of, March 1963, after my brother George had attended a meeting over at the SNCC office,
it's when he came home, somebody evidently had followed the car that dropped him off,
and they, somebody came by and blasted the house with shotgun, you know, through the front door and through the front bedroom.
So that, this, this was all the scary tactics that was happening to people, you know.
Did you have to obey?
No. I mean, if anything, my father said that this is more, this is a clear indication that we have to do something.
Because they're doing things to us, no matter whether we do something or not, and we have to change the way things are.
However, for some of the people who I knew at school, they did not, their parents didn't want them involved with us,
because they were afraid that we were going to get them in trouble.
You know, I mean, people, I mean, and that was the whole fear, is that you were going to get me in trouble, you know.
And, and it was my senior year in high school, and people applying for the schools, and they're trying to, you know, get scholarships,
and they don't want you to do anything that they feel that may jeopardize their chance for something to happen.
But you felt confident.
Well, I did. I mean, as far as I'm concerned, my parents were, my father was definitely very, very supportive of us being involved in the movement and stuff.
And, and I went on that September to Dillard University in New Orleans. I mean, I, but it was like, I wanted to do, I did not want to go to school in Mississippi.
I wanted to, I wanted to go somewhere to see something.
So, and I was also at that time interested in nursing, and Dillard had a nursing program.
So, and it was the first time I'd ever been to Dillard with when I took the train.
My folks carried me to Winona, which was 25 miles away, and took the train down, and went to school.
That's how you got to know Dillard.
That's how I got to know Dillard. So, it was no college visits.
Yeah.
Did you, were you around when they had the festival album, this is the movies, far with different singers?
Oh, yes indeed. There's no question about it. It is Pete Seeger and all of that.
You know, Pete Seeger came down, Pete Seeger and all of that.
And then the papers talked about him all, it's being commoners.
Dad said, that's the, he said, you know, they talk about everybody who want to do something to help the black folks.
So, it was like, I mean, that was a big concern.
And I think that it was one of the kinds of things that helped people like me see that there were other people who definitely thought that you deserved an opportunity to be able to do something.
So, you remember the day and you remember being out on the farm?
I remember being out on the farm. I remember hearing Pete Seeger and, you know, and...
The Freedom Singers perform?
Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, no, no. That was a big, big cultural enrichment for the black community.
And I think it was those kinds of things. It was also as the free Southern theater began to travel throughout Mississippi and do plays that it became very clear that you could have...
You could get a chance to see other kinds of activities, you know, and if you would not just regulate it to a segregated school with no opportunity to do something.
And Pete, that's what's the encouragement to do something else, you know.
I mean, I honestly think that I think that teachers in school always... I mean, they taught the schoolwork, that's all, but it was clearly a line that they didn't talk about doing other things, you know.
I mean, they're exposure, and then I guess part of it was because most of the...
All of them had either gone to Jackson State or they had gone to Alabama State. I mean, these were all teachers and education was the only thing that they knew and they didn't think about how things could be.
What was it like for you to be so involved in the movement and then lead to go to college?
I mean, that was very hard. It was very hard because when it was time for me to go to college, we had just had some big demonstrations in Greenwood.
And they had arrested my brother George and they had made off a card, none of that, and then Hollis. And it was a big group of them that were down in Parchman Farm.
They had sent them down to Parchman Farm because they arrested them and they had to try to transfer them down to Parchman Farm, probably within a day of that whole big process.
What was it being charged with?
Trust passed and was always, you know.
Since we lived so close to Greenwood to downtown, when they actually brought in the...
Had the police dogs, we could hear the dogs barking at my house.
Yeah, I mean, the dogs are like going to town. The dogs are barking and they had sick the dogs on the people for the marches and all.
They're arrested to group of people, sent them down to Parchman Farm and now it's time for me to go away to college.
And my brother is in Parchman Farm, so.
School together, right? Yeah. Yeah, so we've gone to school together. So I was really concerned.
I remembered talking to my daddy about that being very concerned and I remember talking with James Forman.
James Forman was a good mentor for me and I really did like him very much.
And I remember saying to Jim saying, well, don't worry, we're going to look out for George (her brother George) for you, but you go on and get your school and he said,
because this is going to help you and you're going to be able to do so much more when you come back.
So I went on off to Dillard University for my freshman year and I was there. I was at Dillard University when they bombed the church in Alabama.
No, the girls would kill. So I mean, that was like really very, very shocking because it was like, it seemed as if that nothing was ever going to stop.
And that they've been all of this. This is also after the time, Medgar Evers have been killed.
You know, they've been the gunshots in my house. It just seems as if so it's very hard studying and stuff and being separated from all that was going on.
Because at Dillard University, nobody was concerned. Nobody was interested in a movement.
I mean, they did not have any student group at all. Now, I did make connections with Tulane.
I, Cathy Cade (likely) or Casey Hayden was over in Tulane in the Newman Center.
She had been in Albany?
Yeah, she had been, she had been somewhere in Southwest Georgia. But I can't remember. She had been somewhere because she, someone had given her my name and told her I was at Dillard University.
And she came over because during the time when I was at Dillard University, girls were, rules and regulations for girls in schools was extremely strict.
It was harder. My rules were tighter than my mom and dad had ever had. So, Kathy could come over to visit me. But I couldn't go to visit her.
So I went to visit her and then I had to get parents permission for her to be able to take me, for me to ride in a car, to go to Tulane.
Because Tulane did have some student group. They wasn't that active, but they were, they were, they were, they were at least a group.
Since Dillard University had nothing. So I got involved. I went over to see them after I got my parents permission, a letter from my parents and all of that, given them.
And you got to send all of this by mail because we don't have this fast letters of communication. So that was very interesting.
Interesting times just being there. So then I find out for my brother George that there's going to be this big summer project that summer of 64.
And so I of course I'm all interested in doing that. But since I've been away from home, I don't want to go back to Greenwood.
I want to go somewhere. So George tells me that he's going to be working in a project in McComb, Mississippi, Mississippi. And he said, you know, I'll talk to dad and let's see about where it's going to be okay for you to come to McComb, Mississippi.
So I go and I, I, I, I, George helped me get that in my mom to agree for me to like go and work in McComb, Mississippi doing the summer of 64.
But prior to the summer of 64, I went to the orientation up in Ohio.
So was your brother to get more freedom than you did?
Oh, yeah. I mean, it's no question about just partially because one he was older partially because he was a boy.
I mean, so it's no question about is they were much, much more rules were much more strict on girls than we're on boys and stuff.
So like George could drive. Actually, George taught me to drive.
My father had taught my oldest two brothers to drive and when George was a little boy, because he was younger than them.
He used to, when daddy would go to sleep, he was still the car that teached and so George technically told himself to drive.
But he was, he was determined to drive. So he learned to drive and then he taught me to drive.
So, but George, George was a big car person, loved to drive all around.
So he convinced me to come to McComb, Mississippi. I went to McComb, Mississippi, went to the orientation up in Ohio. Then we came back to McComb, Mississippi.
But I was here in Washington because the group that was going to go to McComb, Mississippi came from Ohio over to Washington to meet with the try to see the volunteers.
So they came with the volunteers over here to try to meet with their congressional representatives to ask for additional protection for them while we were in Mississippi during the summer project.
So, what, that partially the group that was going to be in Southwest Mississippi because they figured Southwest was going to be worse.
So we came in to discuss with Congress people the representatives for the volunteers who was going on that project.
We were here when the word came to Ohio that Schwerner, Chaney, and Goodman and, and Goodman had been kidnapped.
So then we got that message and we went immediately back to, to Ohio for that.
Now there's no question about it is when I arrived in Ohio, it was very clear. Everybody felt that the people were dead.
So I think that among the staff, the SNCC staff and the, the, the whole summer project staff, they definitely felt that they were dead.
And then the question was what, what Mississippi or what the FBI in the Bay was going to do anything about it.
So that group organized a search group that then went into Mississippi to try to look for it.
But then I'm sure you recognize that whole story of what happened.
But I went on to McComb.
And I would, we worked, we divided up the, the, the work in McComb that was the freedom schools, that was the people who canvass to try to get it.
We also took terms with cleaning up the house. We had this one freedom house that all of 11 of us that was staying there.
In that process, our house, we used to take terms, supposedly, staying awake to God to protect everybody else.
Unfortunately, the night, that, the night before that happened, we had had this big staff meeting there at the house trying to decide whether it was time for the other volunteers to come down there.
Because we had been down there for, for two weeks and we needed help.
And whether, what, why they were in the way for the other volunteers.
Well, they wanted to make sure that it was safe.
And, and so first we just carried in half the volunteers went into that group, into that.
Because McComb was considered to be a hotbed. So whether it was going to be safe.
We went down for two weeks, worked hard and they just felt that, that it, things had gone very well.
They had, we had a big staff meeting there at the house. Everybody voted, everybody voted for the other volunteers to come, except my brother George, who felt they was not, he said.
I don't want to be responsible for somebody getting hurt. So we bring down more people, it's going to be more responsible.
But since we voted for it, he was outvoted, that night the house was bombed.
So the, they have, basically somebody really walked up to the garage door and put down a couple sticks. So, dynamite.
Now, it took out the garage door, it shattered windows and houses for people from two blocks away.
And no one would seriously hurt, courageous haze, who would sleep and very close to the door, head like fragments of glass that was really implanted in him.
Nobody really got seriously hurt. My brother George, the next death that morning after we, after that whole bombing drove, heard his back up to Jackson, so that he could be a Xamarin by the doctor so we can make sure that nothing really had gone, that no one was really hurt.
What was your life to be in that situation?
Now, you know, I heard this loud explosion and I was asleep. And, but I woke me up and I instantly, I thought they were out there playing.
I couldn't understand. And it was like, I came out of the room and somebody yelled, get down, get down. And then it turns out, I mean, it was like all of a sudden.
And then it was like, we were, the other guys were on the floor and it was like, you know, something has happened.
And it was like, all of a sudden we were crawling toward the garage and you can see that the half of the house has been taken away, whether it's been really bombed.
Now, that was really very frightening.
And we, the police came and they, they pretended like they didn't understand what had happened, you know, and say, what did y'all do, you know, to this house, you know, so it's, it's like, it's a strange kind of thing.
The call is made to Jackson and also to Greenwood, which is where the National Office for Snick was the summer of 6th of 4.
They temporarily moved the National Office to Greenwood, so they relayed over what had happened down there. And George is going to take Curtis into Jackson as soon as they like comes in to see the doctor.
And the next day as you're walking around, we decided that we have to, the keep the community calm, we have to go on as a normal day in campus and in and off.
But as you are walking down the street, it's very clear, people are closing their doors when they say, they're just, I mean, they're just, and this is all the fear that people are really very, very much afraid.
So they are just a very afraid that's, that's something is going to happen, you know. And we are trying our best to act as normal and to keep things going as normally as possible.
Were there any lights in the cone to spoke out against the violence or anything?
Not really. What there was, and I can't think of the family doing the, yes. This is the relationship, because that's how the story and what actually happened is slightly different.
There was a minister from Oregon who had known him while they were in the military. And they were, the chaplains, the chaplains, yeah.
He had known that they have not done the military and they over time had, the families had just changed Christmas cards back with some force. And then when he came there, he wanted to go and visit him.
Because this is somebody that, that he known for the military and he wanted to go and visit.
This is one of the volunteers. He's a minister. He wants to go and visit and we all have this discussion about whether this visit should take place.
But then they decided that he could go, but he was also going to take with him one of the other volunteers that were there. And we picked out the one guy that he was going to take.
Dennis Sweeney, who was a Stanford student, white, blonde, blue eyes. And it's like the two of them could very easily pass off as father and son, father and uncle.
And they would not be noticeable. They would go and visit. So technically they went to Vicks, the Heffners. Now, as the Heffners now tell the story that they made the overture, but it actually happened the other way around.
And then the minister went in to visit them. And I mean, actually, of course he's shocked to see him standing on his doorstep. But the Heffners were, what's considered to be a freedom, I mean, their daughter had been, they run up to Mississippi.
And they knew that they were a respected family. They own the hardware store in downtown. But as a result of this visit from then that point on, the white folks there gave them a complete hard time and they in return left.
But there was none that came out to our support.
So nobody's saying anything in the face of even the house being bombed.
Even that the house being bombed. No, no one is saying anything. The house is bombed and are all around the county.
There were, I think nine different churches that were set afi a black church that was set afi and nobody is saying anything.
It was extremely hard because it's like people, you are one you could die. Secondly is that you could definitely lose what little you have, you know, people are all just very much afraid.
So it's, it's, you are definitely putting your life on the line.
Were you involved in organizing the MFP?
Well, that's basically what we are doing. We are canvassing, getting people, we're going to setting up little meetings to vote for our delegates and all of that. And that's basically what we, what that's the project that I'm working on because some people are dealing with the freedom schools that was that was going on.
And it was a very short summer. So we are trying to get that organized and we get our delegates selected and then I go up with them to Atlantic City for the convention, the democratic convention.
I mean, that was definitely a mind blowing event because one is it's something that I had never considered that was possible that we could go.
And my father said to he died and he said, I don't care whether they see the does or not. We showed everybody that it was possible for us to go and we could present our case for the whole country to see.
And then I think that that that was probably one of the biggest things that people really did feel that now at least it's open up and so when Miss Hamer is making her speech that becomes world wide and the people.
It's like all of a sudden people know what they are doing to us.
You know, and now they have to make that decision about which side they are really on.
Were you disappointed at the compromise that was offered?
Well, I must admit is I really thought we were going to win. I thought I honestly felt that the delegates were going to say yes, you are all the legitimate group.
You should have the seat. You know, but I think that what it did it exposed me to family that I just thought it was just Mississippi the tree that does like that.
Not realize that Mississippi was able to do that because the rest of the country didn't care.
But that's when it really became very, very clear. There wasn't just bad white folks in Mississippi.
There were a lot of these people and that bad white folks in Mississippi had been able to do all of this to all of us down in Mississippi because the rest of the people did not care.
Well, after that summer, I went back to Dilup for my second year and that was the hardest year.
I mean, it was just very hard. I mean, it was very hard because I definitely felt that we needed to do something to make changes.
And I felt that we needed to make changes. And everybody that was going to school with kept saying, well, you know, you finished school, you get yourself a good job and you can have a good life.
And it's just, I just didn't feel that that's, I mean, it just seemed to me that I felt that there was basic changes in this country that we needed to make and we needed to have.
And I needed to do things. I mean, I could not just keep studying and stuff and then just keep hoping and keep saying that I'll get a job and I will fix it.
And I will be successful, you know, and the world will go on. And people kept saying, well, folks are doing bad because they don't have an education.
You know, and we were like, they don't have an education because the system that we live on is so structured that people can't get an education and you can't have a good life.
Well, when you, after that summer in McComb, Mississippi that fall, wasn't there just like bombing after that?
That was. I mean, it was not only in McComb, Mississippi, but it was like everywhere and it was like, and it could get to be very interesting.
You could have one conversation with somebody, they said, well, you know, these people, what, what causes trouble things wouldn't be having them.
You said, well, we have to make changes.
So you're the, you're the girl?
Yeah, well, it was like, that's where the question gets to be. Some people would say that if we just set back things are going to change, things are going to get better.
And you just said, well, things will not change on that. People just don't, they just don't just decide one day we're going to build good schools, good hospitals for everybody.
And everybody's going to have an opportunity.
So to make this happen, people have to do the active.
And so at the end of my second year, I knew I couldn't go back. One is I didn't want nursing in the longer.
And I couldn't go back to Dillard anyway, because I just, I could not stand the idea that all I need to do was get myself a good education, get a good job, and have a good life.
And I wanted basically the system to change. And I wanted for it to be decent houses, decent places for everyone to live, and opportunities for people.
And it had to be more than just education. I mean, it had to be. So, I mean, it's healthcare.
And healthcare conditions in Mississippi was very, was deplorable. People never went to the doctors and stuff.
I think if it wasn't for the, the shots that were given in the school systems, the vaccinations and all of that, people wouldn't have had anything.
Because of public health, they at least gave you vaccinations in schools. Yeah.
What did you do when you left Dillard?
I left Dillard and I went, went back to work in, worked in Jackson on a voter registration. And we, to some of six to five, there was massive demonstrations in Jackson.
And I was involved in all of those demonstrations. What they did in Jackson is they sent the black people to the fairground.
They set the fairground up as a penitentiary. So, I spent a week there in the fairground, the penitentiary, and they put the white women that were arrested in the actual jail.
What was it like in this kind of week at the fairground in the jail?
Well, the first thing is the fairground. You're sleeping on a concrete floor and they basically give you a blanket at night.
At nine o'clock every night they give you these blankets. But we're, I mean, it's a huge tent at the fairground.
And the tent is constructed over this concrete floor. So you're sleeping on a desk. So it's no picnic.
And basically the way the food is that it is a tray, a 10 tray that you get. And your breakfast is syrup or slice of light bread.
And you're going through and then you're getting your food. Then after you eat, you go then and dip your tray into this hot thing of water.
And that's how it's washed and it's stacked on and you're doing this. And it's like a couple hundred people. So this is like a line of people going through there.
For lunch you get some type of grits. And for this the same process is same 10 tray that you're going through doing.
And it's, you know, it's a very harsh condition, you know, on the fairground. And by the time I went in, people had been there for a couple of weeks and people were getting very upset.
Because this is the pressing condition and nobody really knows when they're going to come out.
So part of the process of the later photo in like me is to try to help lift up the morale.
Going on the potential?
Yeah, just to encourage people to stay on because we don't know. For that present time they're trying to raise money to get all these people out of jail and you have no idea.
So you're really trying your best to encourage people. You know, trying as much as possible the most of the Janet Moses and I went in at the same time.
It's hard. No, I mean you can understand the reluctance. But there's nothing that you can do. So you're getting you up at six o'clock and you're going to bed at nine.
We're going to bed. You're laying on this concrete, you know, with a blanket so that a mat and sleep in on a concrete.
What's the issue?
I mean, it still is a question in terms of registered and devolved. I mean, this is still I mean, the summer 65 is before the civil rights, the civil rights bill.
I believe it's signed that fall.
Yeah, it's all got said. Well, this is all right prior to that. Yeah, to that.
I mean, I know that there were huge arrests and a huge arrest.
Yeah, and the fairground was the.
When I got back out of jail, I went that's when I actually moved over to Atlanta.
I went to work in the Atlanta Snick office. Now originally started out. I mean, and Jim form was also part of my motivation for going to gym and was trying his best to keep.
He was the executive secretary of Snick and he was he would gym was a organizational person.
So he was always trying to mix the groups of people and so he encouraged me to come to work in Atlanta office to and I worked on the switchboard.
You want people who have been in the field to work in the office some and some of the people who are in the office to work in the field, you know.
So you put people to understand the organization. I think it was a way it was also a way to do that.
And it helped you to understand what was going on in the organization.
And for all of us who had been in the field since sometimes they had been complaints that you didn't feel that other people were as understanding as they may have been.
Having people from that helps with that because also you get to know each other and you can discuss it's different issues and all.
So the standout team, you organization in general, or from your time in the office?
Well, I went to work at the switchboard but I also was working very closely with Ruby Doris Smith Robinson.
Now Rubidorus was also just like, in a lot of ways she was like Jim. She was like a woman, had graduated from Spelman.
She had also been a Freedom Rider and stuff. And she had also been one of my heroes because I had met her at a Snick conference once before.
And you know, she was a few years older than me. She had graduated from college and Rubid just seemed to have done everything.
But she was also an organizational person. Rubid also would say that nobody couldn't have worked her.
They couldn't out drive her. She was, no, she was just, in everything that she did she was just terrific.
She always encouraged you to do just as much. So it was like she was always telling me that Freddie, what you want to do is learn as much stuff,
as much different things as you can. So you can always decide upon what you really like.
Most people say, because they've only done one thing in life and they just say, this is me. This is the kind of thing.
She said, but you know, that's because they never saw anything and never did anything else. So you tried doing all these different kinds of things.
And she was one of the people who got me involved in finance. Growing up in Mississippi, I would never find a suit, find an ass.
And I was like, I'm not doing a business career. I'm understanding how offices function, how to count in and all of this.
But this was all far and this is all results of Ruby and Jim basically encouraging me to do different things.
And also they're always encouraging you to read things and telling you about something.
So you move on to the Atlanta office. Does your brother George, does he continue organizing in the field?
George stays in the field. He goes from Mississippi into George and into Alabama.
Because doing 65 as Nick begins to set up more projects, you know, the Lowndes County, Alabama County Project, the Greene County, Alabama Project.
George is working in Lions County. He's a field person. He would have never made it in an office.
He just, in terms of personnel, he's just like going more, going in the field. He's like going out, canvassing, talking to the people and stuff.
You know, he liked that a lot more.
Who else were you working with in the Atlanta office? What are some of the things that are going on?
Well, I'm going, I go to work in the Atlanta office and I get involved in the finance.
First I'm doing the switchboard, then I'm helping Chessie Johnson, who is a SNCC bookkeeper in terms of the finances of that.
So it's like we're receiving in all the checks in terms of donations and all of that that's being made.
Now, I'm there in the Atlanta office at the same time when we, like, Stokely Carmichael called Michael, who I have grown to love and consider him like my brother and stuff,
because he lived with my family when he's in Mississippi and stuff and all and doing the whole time in, no, we were talking about going into 66 when black power comes out.
So it's no question about it. It's as a result of the shouting of black power on the Meredith March Against Fear, I experienced the direct process that's next money is just beginning to just really drop off.
I mean, people are just very uptight about the money. I mean, they just, what does, I mean, it's the news meeting.
What does, tell me what black power means. What does this, you know, and I definitely feel that the media definitely came after us in strong motions,
that what are you all talking about with black power? I mean, what are you all going to set up a separate nation, you know, that was, in my opinion, one of the big changes in the whole process, you know, and then when Snick decided to, at one of the staff meetings, that the white staff people were working to work communities in the black, when they in the black community.
I mean, the news plate is up much more than I think that the staff talked about it as. I mean, we basically talked about this is, these are the problems that we have.
We have problems in the white community, we have problems in the black community, we feel that the problems in the black community will be better solved by black staff members working on it.
And the white staff, we feel that they could contribute a lot more if they could help change some of the problems that we have in the white community.
Were you on the, were you still on Snick's staff when Robert Parris Moses Zellner and Dottie Zellner made a proposal about staying on staff and working in the white community? I think this was in 1967.
Well, I was still on staff, yeah, yeah, I actually left Snick in 1968, June of 1968, after, you know, King was killed in April. And I think pretty much by 68, we were beginning to, because the money was all gone.
Do you remember their proposal? I'm not sure about that remembering that proposal. I do remember that, I mean, I know Robert Parris Moses and Daddy both quite well, yeah.
Yeah.
You mentioned that Stokey used to stay with your family.
Yes.
So, what do you like? Well, Stokey was a tall, dark, handsome young man. And, and, and, and he said, a very nice person and a personable person.
I think I'm not sure whether it was joy or whether it was my brother, Dwight, one of them brought him home to, to our house in like in 62.
And then from that point on, whenever Stokey was in Greenwood, he always stayed with my family. And he, my family did, I mean, you know, since I've known, I mean, families took in civil rights workers. That's how people worked, you know, so that,
but Stokey was a regular stay at my family's house. I mean, he was always personable, you know. And, and he always talked about, you know, his family, you know, so it was like, and, and, and he used to talk about his group, the group of students that he worked with at Howard.
So, when I knew him, he was going back with some folks. He would be in Mississippi in the summertime and back at Howard. He was telling me about, oh, he, when I told him I was going to go to work in McComb, Mississippi for the summer, six of, he said, oh, you're making a mistake.
He said, I'm bringing back all my people and said that the whole,
inverter content is love. Convert operational district is going to be just flooded with all of my NAG. And he said, you're going to want to be down there, you're going to be sorry.
Yeah, but he could make himself at much at home with anybody. I mean, he could sit down and he could really talk to you.
And not in a balloon way, and it was always trying to,
no, it's always done encouragement and always to talk about,
what we have in common, how we can do things
to make a difference in the world.
Well, you know, so you know all these college students
like it to balloon, probably?
And yo, yeah!
But they didn't persuade you to go to school with them, right?
No, no, no.
I don't think they could have possibly been persuade.
I wanted to leave the state.
I want, I'm telling you, it's like,
I mean, it's growing up in Mississippi
and wanting to see what's out there in the rest of the world.
And I think that that was one of the biggest things
that impressed me the most is that when I met people like,
now, I'm marrying right, Elemon, you know,
all these people I'm meeting when I'm in high school.
And they are from different places
and they have done and are doing things now to help us.
And I just see this as really making a difference.
No, I had met both Joyce Ladner and Dorie Ann Ladner,
who are also from Mississippi and stuff,
but I had no interest in going to,
to go into Gulu.
And actually, one night,
this is when I think about Dorie Ann Ladner is,
this is, I mean, movement people make connections
with people and they just have friends.
And it's like,
Stokely Carmichael and Dorie Ann Ladner are in New Orleans when I'm at Dillard.
And it's after hours for girls to receive gifts.
So they have come down for Mardi Gras, right?
And so, so they decide that they know I'm there
in school and they know I'm in the dormitory
because it's after so late,
you can't be anywhere but in the dormitory.
So they come by to see me at the school.
They tell the house mother at the dormitory
that they are my sisters and brothers.
And they come up, please.
And she agreed to get sent up me for my room
and I come down and all of a sudden,
so I'm like, overwhelm.
I'm just so happy to see Stokely Carmichael and Dorie Ann Ladner
and they have come to visit me as my son.
That's wonderful.
I mean, that's the way movement people were, you know?
So are there things that you would want people
to know about the movement?
I think that one of the biggest things that I found
is that it had the ability to attract people
from all facets of life.
And everybody, Robert Parris Moses and Jim,
and everybody that I came in contact with
always tried to do things to help you
and always tried to do things to help you
expose other people to doing something
to make a difference.
And I never felt that anybody was looking
for any personal advancement.
It wasn't like, you know, I want to be the richest person.
I want to do something to help somebody else.
And I think that was the one of the things
that impressed me the most about it.
You know, I mean, I met Robert Parris Moses, no.
I mean, you're talking about people who all
who had possibilities to live, come to realize
and yet they were willing to set this aside
to come to help somebody else.
Yeah, okay.
We're sorry, are we gonna say something now?
No.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my God.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture.